[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROBERT KUBIS: All right,
all right, hello, everyone.
How are you doing?
OK.
Good.
I hope there is still some
more people coming in, probably
getting out from the keynote.
I really appreciate that you
came here to watch my talk.
I'm going to talk about
building a powerful data back
end for Mobile Unwrap.
A little bit about myself--
I'm a cloud developer advocate.
So basically, I'm the interface
between the people that
build the technology
inside of Google
and people that build on the
technology outside of Google.
So hopefully you
guys and girls are
going to take something
out of this talk
and build something
amazing afterwards.
Before I start, I want to get
a little bit of a feel of who
am I talking to.
So who of you here
is a developer?
All right, that's amazing.
You are in the right place.
Who is an Android developer?
Who has done something
with Firebase?
All right, a lot.
Back end developers?
Anyone who develops
with Golang Awesome.
Cool.
So my favorite languages
are Golang and Java.
So I'm going to stick to Java in
this talk to reach the biggest
audience basically.
So let's get started.
So if we choose
the right storage,
it is actually a really,
really big problem.
This is really hard to do.
So we have a lot of
things to consider
when you choose your storage
system, things like--
what's the object size?
What's the scale that you need?
What are the latency
requirements, throughput,
consistencies, and permissions?
Things like that.
So there are a lot
of things that you
need to consider when choosing
the right storage system.
Now, when I created this
talk, I was thinking,
like, what am I
going to talk about?
Or how am I going to
construct this talk?
So I was wondering
if I should start--
oh, I have to get it out--
like 20 years ago,
pretty much, where
you had storage systems
which are mostly local
or things like that.
Who still remember this?
I actually even started with
the 5 and 1/4 zoll diskettes,
but they are pretty amazing.
But I thought, I'm
not going to bore you
with history like 20 years ago.
Even so, it's amazing.
It's really interesting.
And everybody should
look into that.
But we are living in the now
and almost in the future.
So I'm going to talk a
little bit about the things
that you can do today.
So how can I do that?
I didn't want to go
through a dry talk
in the sense of talking you
through the different options
that you have, like with
Firebase, or with Google Cloud
Platform.
I wanted to make that a
little bit more entertaining.
So I thought, let's do this
and create a sample app.
OK.
So here's my startup idea.
I'm a cloud developer advocate.
So, for me, everything
is about the cloud.
So my startup idea
is Cloudy.pictures.
So concentrate on one thing
and do one thing well.
This is where I want to get
to by the end of the talk.
I want to have an app where you
can upload pictures, where you
can crop and resize the picture,
where you can store metadata,
and then, of course,
display the pictures.
All right, so what do we
have in terms of options?
Now, I saw a couple of you
are Firebase developers.
For the ones that haven't
touched Firebase so far,
I really recommend
to look into that.
Firebase gives you a lot
of things, a lot of tools
to build applications,
especially mobile applications,
be it Android, iOS,
or a web application.
You have things like
authentication, hosting,
Firestore, which gives
you a flexible data
storage for metadata.
You have cloud
storage for Firebase.
And you have even
something that can
execute server side code called
Cloud Functions for Firebase.
Now, there might
be situations where
you have to get out of
this, where you want
to do a little bit more
sophisticated tasks, things
that you can't cover
with Cloud Function.
There are limitations
with Cloud Functions,
and there are reasons to
break out of this ecosystem.
So that's where Google
Cloud Platform comes in.
With Google Cloud
Platform, you have
a multitude of tools at your
disposal that you can use.
On the one hand, you
have compute from--
there are VMs where you can
do pretty much everything
that you want, almost, up
to Cloud Functions as well.
So you have a multitude
of compute that you
can use to do your things.
We also have a multitude
of storage products
under the Google Cloud
Platform portfolio.
Some of these
products are actually
the exact same products that
you can use with Firebase.
So you can think that you
have different interfaces
to the same product, which
makes it actually easier
to deal with them for
different use cases.
So if you build a web app, it's
easier to use the Firebase SDK.
If you build a back end system,
you can use outlined libraries
on the Google Cloud platform.
So the first thing when
we upload a picture is we
need a place to
store our pictures.
So that's where Google Cloud
Storage comes in, or cloud
storage for Firebase.
As said, they're both
the same product.
The product is actually a highly
available, durable, simple and
secure object storage.
What does that mean?
What is an object storage?
So object storage is pretty
much every kind of blob
that you can think of.
A blob is basically bytes.
So it can be images.
It can be videos.
It can be normal files.
It can pretty much be any
byte stream that you can find.
Now, cloud storage is
optimized for user latency,
for end user latency.
There are a lot of
things that you can do.
You can define the caching
strategy, things like that.
You can make your object storage
public so that people outside
can access it.
You can actually
make it in a sense
that other people
pay for the access
to your cloud storage system.
It is integrated with over
100 end points, or cloud POPs
that we call.
So basically if somebody
comes in from, let's say,
Asia or Europe, they
go to the closest POP,
which is connected to their
internet service provider.
And then they go directly
into our Google network.
And that means the latency
to retrieve objects, or even
store objects, are minimized.
So it's a really good
tool for our app.
That's exactly what
we want and need.
All right, so we're going to
start with creating a bucket.
So a bucket is a unique
route end point, so to say,
that you have to create to
be able to store some data.
When you create a bucket,
you will define things
like the storage
class and the location
where your bucket lives.
So in this case, as you can
see here, I have two examples.
Either you use our
CLI with gsutil.
You make a bucket.
You define the storage class.
In this case, it's
multi-regional.
And then my storage
is cloudy-pictures.
You can do the same with
Java if you want to.
So if you want to create
buckets programmatically,
you can use our storage APIs,
and then basically directly
created from your Java program.
All right, the next step
is uploading a file.
Again, very easy if
you're familiar with
CP on any kind of
operating system.
You just prepend
it with gsutil-cm,
which allows you to actually
multicast your upload.
And then you upload
a picture here
to our cloud storage bucket.
In Java, pretty much simple
and straightforward as well.
You select the file,
or you point to a file.
You make a byte area out of it.
You put it in a bucket,
and create it with a name,
as you can see here.
In this example, I actually
also gave it the content type
that you can do as well.
If you want to do
it from the web,
for the ones that have done
Firebase, this looks familiar.
So basically, you use
the Firebase web SDKs.
You get the storage reference.
You use a file reader.
From your input field you get
the file name and the content.
And you upload that to storage--
very straightforward.
That we use as well for our app.
And next, last but not least for
storage, is how to read a file.
And, again, it's
very straightforward.
You can do a copy,
like download it.
You can use Java,
the blob object,
and read it from your bucket.
Or on the web, you basically
get a download URL.
And then you use
this download URL,
and put it in, for
instance, your image tag,
or your background
image CSS attribute.
All right, so that's great.
We uploaded all our pictures,
or we uploaded one picture.
Now, how can I do processing?
If I upload a picture from
my phone, or from my camera,
these pictures are large.
They are like megabytes.
And I don't want to serve
megabytes of pictures
always to my web
page or to my users.
That would strain
the bandwidth a lot.
So what I want to do is
I want to actually create
some thumbnails.
Now, there is the possibility
that you create thumbnails
already on your clients.
But I don't think
that is a good idea.
There are many reasons
for not doing this.
Now, I can create
thumbnails on the back end,
which I'm going to use.
And I could trigger
the thumbnail creation
from my clients.
I don't think that is
a good idea either.
What happens if you
upload a picture,
and then you get disconnected,
or the thumbnail creation fails
and you need to retry it?
All of this logic would be
cluttering your front end
and your client code.
You want to do these
things on the back end.
So I want to use a
different mechanism
to actually trigger the
processing of my image files.
And that's where object
notifications come in.
So object notifications
on Google Cloud Storage
allows you to basically
register a hook which
gets called if anything
happens on your storage system.
So there are four
event types that you
can hook your systems up to.
It's also finalized, which
is basically object create.
It's an object delete.
And it's archiving of an object.
And it's any kind
of metadata update
that you do on your objects.
So you can hook into
any of these events.
And there are different
mechanisms to hook
into these events.
There are three main
mechanisms that you can use.
On one hand, if you use
Firebase and Cloud Functions,
you can use the cloud storage
trigger for Cloud Functions.
So basically, if you
submit your function,
you can say these functions
get triggered if anything
happens on my bucket.
This is actually integrated with
the Cloud Pub/Sub notification
system.
So Cloud Pup/Sub
notification also
allows you to set a notification
watch command on your bucket
and say, if anything
happens of these events
that I declare, please
send me a Pub/Sub message.
And then you can
have a system that
deals with the Pub/Sub message.
And kind of the legacy object
change notifications that
are still around are
what we introduced
very early on in the Google
Cloud storage product.
It's the object
change notification.
So if you register an
object change notification,
you'll basically get an HTTPS
call to an HTTPS end point.
And then you can deal with
the message there as well.
The nice thing about
this is all of this
what you're using here,
if you set this up,
is integrate in an array
that it does all the retry.
So if you don't acknowledge
a successful processing
of the message, the system
just retries it automatically,
up to 30 days.
All right, so how do I
setup Cloud Pub/Sub trigger?
Here's an example.
I'm using the gcloud
Pub/Sub gcloud SDK, or CLI.
So I do gcloud pubsub
topics create notifs.
I declare a notification.
I create here, in this
case, a notification
against my cloudy
pictures buckets.
And I say I only want
to have notifications
when object finalize
is happening,
so when an object is created.
And then I declare the topic
where this notification
is going to be sent to.
And then if I want
to have a system that
receives these
messages, I create
a so-called subscription.
Here gcloud pubsub
subscription create
pops up, and notifsub, which
basically hooks to the topic
that I just created.
All right, so let me show you
how that looks really quick.
So I want to show you
here my application.
Right now it's pretty empty.
If I refresh this,
nothing is happening.
So throughout this
talk, I actually
want to fill this with pictures.
So I can assure you, if
I upload a picture here,
I just select one picture,
I'm going to do upload,
and it's going to upload,
but pretty much nothing else
is going to happen.
So if I'm going to
refresh my page,
this picture is actually
going to be gone.
So I need to implement all
the things behind the scenes
to process this picture.
So the first thing
that we're going to do
is I show you how
to create this--
let me make that
a little bigger.
Can you see this?
Thumbs up, thumbs down
if you can see that.
All right, Cool.
So first thing is
gCloud pops up.
And then I say, topic create.
And let's say notifsub.
Oh.
That's wrong.
All right, So I
create my notif topic.
All right, perfect,
that happened.
The next thing that
I'm going to do
is I want to actually
create my watch command.
So now, if you have
spotted, I actually
named the topic differently.
So I'm going to remove this here
and create this notification.
So now what is going
to happen is actually
I'm creating a notification
watch on my storage bucket.
You see here, the storage
is named a little different,
because that is the
storage which I actually
use for my application.
Now, the next thing
that I want to do
is I actually want to see if
any messages are coming in.
So I can do a
Pub/Sub notification.
Sorry.
All right.
So it's subscription.
I just created a subscription.
I actually need to
create a subscription.
I haven't done that.
So I want to create
a subscription which
I call uploads.
Create a subscription.
So now I have a
subscription that
actually listens on that topic.
This is a little slow.
So let me turn off the Wi-Fi
and hope that it works better
without the Wi-Fi.
All right, so now I
want to actually listen
to my Pub/Sub topic.
So I'm going to do
Pub/Sub, Subscription.
And then I can pull.
And I'm not going
to acknowledge,
but I'm going to
pull on uploads.
All right, so as you
can see here right now,
nothing's happening.
See your items.
So let me upload a picture
really quick again.
I'm going to upload
that picture.
And then I'm going to go back
to my system, do pull uploads.
As you can see here,
I have a message.
In this message, as you can
see, it has a lot of things.
There are things
like the ID, the self
link for it, name, the bucket,
generation ID, all these things
that you can use.
All right, so next thing,
let's go back to the slides.
So I have my bucket.
So now if I upload my
pictures and process them,
I want to actually store
some data around this.
So even if I now
process my pictures,
nothing's going to
happen basically.
They're not going to be
displayed in my web page.
So I need something to actually
process them and then store
some metadata around them.
So that's where we
go back and look
at what is the
portfolio of systems
that we have available for us.
And here I'm going
to look at Firestore.
Firestore is the
NoSQL back end system,
which allows you to store
document based data.
And the advantage
of that is actually
that it's very
flexible in a sense.
So if you want to add some
fields or things like that,
you can do that throughout the
lifecycle of your application.
So you don't have to be very
restrictive on the schema
that you are going to use.
You can just evolve
the schema while you
develop your application.
Now, for Firestore, again,
they are client libraries
which you can use from the web,
as well as from your back end
systems.
So Cloud Firestore,
just to summarize again,
it's very flexible.
You have an expressive
query language.
You get real time updates.
If you do Firebased, you can
basically use watch commands
or basically get events for
any data that has changed.
You have offline support if
you do a web application.
And it's designed
to scale again.
So this is a system that
can scale to massive sizes.
So how do you write
data to Firestore?
Here's an example for Java.
So pretty much everything
in Firestore is async.
So as you can see here,
you get a document graph.
You give it a name to your
document, basically an ID.
You have a collection document.
And then you put
your fields in there.
To write this, you
use an API future.
And then you can also update
fields if you want to.
Now, if you read data, it's
pretty much similar to that.
There are not a lot
of changes here.
On the document ref that you
create, you just do a get.
And that blocks till
you have the data.
All right, so let's
see how we can
integrate that to actually write
some data in our application.
So now we are going to
switch to some code.
So what I have here is my
image processing service.
So what I have here is I
basically set up my application
with Google credentials.
So this uses the
default credentials
that you have set,
either if you run
that on a GE instance, a
Compute Engine instance,
then you have a
default context, or you
provide a service account, which
is used to authenticate you.
It's done very easily.
You really need only
these like six lines
to get the credential context.
Now, then we need a project ID.
We define our storage
that we want to use.
So this is, again, cloud
storage for Firebase.
I define here my Pub/Sub
that I have defined.
And I can actually use
this and say, OK, I
created a Pub/Sub
which is uploads.
So I'm going to use
the upload subscription
that I created earlier.
All right, and then this
code, what you see here,
is basically listening
for Pub/Sub messages.
So that's, again, doing
this asynchronously.
Every time I get a message,
I have here my message
that I get.
I'm going to put that
into my processed message
function, which we're going
to look into in a bit.
And then if the function
is actually successful,
I acknowledge this message.
Now, what you have
with Pub/Sub is
you can actually have
multiple subscribers
on the same subscription.
And what happens is
your message gets
round robin distributed to
all the subscribers on one
subscription.
Now, if you want to make sure
that one message is distributed
to multiple places and
always to multiple places,
then you just create
multiple subscriptions.
All right, so let's look
into our process message.
So what we are going
to do here is basically
I'm going to check for
uploads on my image
when it gets uploaded.
And I'm going to show you really
quick we have here our storage
system.
If I go to storage,
you're going to see here I
have some images
that are the two
images that I uploaded earlier.
All right, and then I
basically take the parse,
take the user ID out of this,
take the file ID out of it,
do some resizing.
I'm doing the resizing
here with ImageMagick.
So that's the reason I wanted
to run this on a GC instance,
for instance.
I store the sums in my
bucket, as you can see here
in the create function.
I have a 600 pixel wide
thumbnail and a 1,600
pixel wide thumbnail.
And then I just create and
move this object as well
to a different folder that's not
in my uploads folder anymore.
And last but not least, I just
clean up all my temporary files
that I had in between.
So now, as you can see,
I just started that.
So let's see what's
going to happen.
Since we uploaded some pictures
earlier on this subscription,
it should actually get these.
As you can see now, it
actually gets these messages
and does all the processing.
So let's have a look at
what that looks like.
So we see here that
we have our messages.
On my storage we can see
if anything's happening.
OK.
We have actually uploads
and raw images now.
So we have images moving.
Great.
Amazing.
And then let's see if any
metadata is coming in.
Metadata is not coming in.
So let's just upload
another picture
and see if our
metadata is coming in.
Actually, I'm not
writing any metadata.
So I actually need to
write my metadata first.
So we need to look
into setting this up
for writing some metadata.
So the first thing is, I
want to have my Firestore--
so Firestore init.
So this takes the
credentials, again,
and initialises my Firebased
app and my Firestore.
And the next step is,
before I move my data
to the raw folder--
or actually, let's do it
by [INAUDIBLE] after that.
I want to update my
Firestore metadata.
So here I'm just going to
add three fields, the process
field, a small available field,
and a large available field.
All right, I'm
going to save this.
I'm going to restart
my application.
Something is missing.
All right, Firebase
is not there.
Firestore-- all right.
Of course, we need to
actually provide this here.
So Firestore.
And then here I want to
provide my Firestore.
All right, let's try this again.
All right, so now it is working.
So let's have a look
if we upload a picture.
OK.
We upload a picture.
So this is actually
just client side
that I display this picture.
So if I refresh, I'm
going to see nothing.
That's OK.
I'm going to see nothing
because it's basically
downloading the file,
doing the ImageMagick,
and then uploading
the file again.
So that will take
a little while.
So we see a new
element coming in.
Let's see if we
get all the stuff.
All right.
OK.
Perfect.
So we have now the
metadata there,
which means our picture was
processed, and first success.
OK.
Awesome.
So we have the
first picture there.
Let's switch back to the slides.
All right, so we have our
first minimal viable product.
So we can upload the picture,
and I can display pictures.
Amazing.
And I can store some
metadata as well on it.
So now, what if our app grows?
A lot of people,
thousands of people,
are starting to upload
cloudy pictures.
I said before, this is
a very targeted app only
for cloudy pictures.
So now what I want
to do is I actually
want to reduce some costs.
In the beginning, you saw
I created a bucket which
is a multi-regional bucket.
So the multi-region
bucket is actually
like our most sophisticated
storage class that we have.
To reduce costs, I have actually
different options and storage
classes that I can use.
There are four storage classes
available under the cloud
storage.
The multi-regional
one is the one
that is distributed
across two regions, which
are at least 100 miles
apart from each other,
and gives you the highest
availability for your needs.
Now, if you do data
processing, and you
want to actually
process your data
close to where it
is living, then we
recommend to use
a regional bucket.
The regional bucket
is one region.
It's a little bit cheaper, and
it gives you a little bit less
of an availability SLA.
Now, when it comes
to archiving data,
we have a nearline and a
coldline storage class.
Nearline is pretty much if your
images or any kind of objects
are not used within 30 days,
you can move them to nearline.
And it's cheaper
actually to use nearline
than have them stored on a
regional or multi-regional
bucket.
Now, if you use your data
less than once a year,
then it's recommended to
move these to coldline.
You still have the
same persistency
of your data objects.
And you still have the same
APIs, which is amazing.
But the prices get up.
Now, one thing which
is really important
to do all these
things automated,
or in your application,
is something called
object lifecycle.
With object lifecycle,
what you can do
is you can define rules for when
the object gets automatically
transitioned between
the storage classes.
So on my bucket I
could define a rule.
If an object is
older than 30 days,
please move it to nearline.
If it is older than like 365
days, or older than 90 days,
please move it to coldline.
But I also can do
that per object.
I don't have to create a bucket
with a specific storage class.
You can do that.
But you don't have to.
You can actually change the
storage class per object.
So what does it look like?
You can use it either with
gsutil and do it there.
Or you can use a Java, as you
see there, to move your object.
So I'm going to show that
really quickly how we're
going to do this here.
So I have a second
application here,
which extracts
some more metadata.
So as you can see here, the
same setup code pretty much.
But what I do is I'm
reading the object,
and then I'm using the SDK
to get EXIF data out of it.
So now when this is
done, what I want to do
is actually I want to
move this object away.
So let's see how we can do this
so we can actually do it here,
and then move the object.
Let's see how we're
going to do this.
All right, there it is.
So basically I take my object.
I just define a
new storage class,
build this, and then say, OK,
when my metadata is processed,
I'm just going to
move it to nearline.
So I'm going to start
this here as well.
And that's going to listen
on my notification as well.
So now, this is a topic
where notifications
have been sent before.
So as you can see, it starts
actually processing as well.
And it might throw
some errors because I
have some deleted some object.
But it basically will process,
in the background, our object.
So let's have a look if
that is actually working.
So what we can have here
is we have our objects.
And in time, what you can see
here is metadata is showing up.
So this gives me
all the EXIF data,
which I now can use
to search for instants
or build a world map where
I can put all my pictures.
And if I go to storage,
which I'm going to do here--
I'm going to go to
my storage system.
cloudy pictures.
I'm going to go to my raws.
Going to see here.
And as you can see,
my pictures actually
now have the storage
system nearline.
So even though I
created this bucket
as a multi-regional bucket,
I'm already moving my objects
into a different storage class,
which is really powerful.
All right, switching back.
All right, so we have that.
We have reduced our costs
by moving our objects
and saving some costs there.
The next thing that I want to
do is enable a business model.
I want to generate
some money with this.
So the app has gone viral.
I have stored a lot of pictures.
And now people
have asked and want
to actually print and
frame, so buy a frame
and ship the pictures.
So I want to enable this.
Now, if I want to do this,
I'm dealing with money.
And if I'm dealing with
money, I need actually
a transactional system.
So I don't want to do
this with Firestore,
because I think my
transactional guarantees that I
have with Firestore are
not sufficient for what
I want to do.
So that's where another
storage system comes in.
And we have a managed
storage system for Cloud SQL.
So Cloud SQL is a
managed RDBMS system.
You can have MySQL or
Postgres as a flavor.
And it gives you things
like automatic updates.
You can do backups.
You can do fail overs.
You can do fail overs
into other people clouds.
You can do fail overs into
on premise systems, things
like that.
It is vertically scalable.
So you can change your node
size throughout the lifecycle
of your application.
And you have things
like a 99.95 SLA.
So how do we create
a MySQL instance?
Again, very straightforward--
gcloud SQL instance create.
You give it a name.
You say the tier,
which is basically
the size that you want to use,
and the region where this cloud
SQL instance is created.
Next thing is I want to talk
to my cloud SQL instance.
So what we provide
is actually a proxy
which automatically
authenticates you
if you provided a service file.
So here what you can
see is you're basically
down your cloud SQL proxy.
And then you make it executable.
And then you can run
it either locally,
or you can run it
on your GC instance.
Or if you are familiar
with Kubernetes,
which is a container
management system,
you can run it directly
in your parts as a sidecar
to connect to your
cloud instance.
That's pretty much
straight forward.
Who here has done something
with MySQL or any SQL database?
All right.
Amazing.
So this looks very familiar.
Relational schema.
I'm creating a database
and some tables.
In this case, I'm
creating a user table,
the Cloudaficionado.
I'm creating a balance
table, which is basically
my account balance.
And I'm creating a
transaction table,
which shows me the history
of the transactions that
have been done.
And then I can do things
like a transaction that
goes across multiple tables.
So here you can see I have
a transaction that actually
takes some money from
the balance table,
puts it somewhere else
in the balance table,
and also writes in
my transaction table
that this has happened.
So it's pretty much
straight forward.
Now, the next step
is my app goes viral.
So now what we want to do is
we need a scalability check.
So when I build my
cloudy pictures 3.0,
I want it to be scalable for
a large amount of people.
So let's check.
Cloud storage is scalable.
Cloud Firestore, or Firestore
on a Firebase is also scalable.
It is a multitenant service.
You don't have to
pre-provision any resources.
You basically just use
it with your application,
and the more you use, it
will scale with your needs.
Amazing.
Now, Cloud SQL, unfortunately,
is one solution that
doesn't scale with your needs.
You can scale it up
to a certain point.
Basically the biggest VM
that your cloud provider,
or, in our case, Google
Cloud Platform, provides you.
But if you run out of the
size of the biggest VM,
you're kind of stuck.
There are many, many
things that you can do.
You can, of course, do sharding,
and build like a distributed
RDBMS.
But it's very challenging and
costs a lot of time investment.
And it's very risky.
So now is where I want
to plug in Cloud Spanner.
Cloud Spanner is our
horizontally scalable
and distributed relational
database system.
So you get strong
consistency with it,
and it scales with your needs.
You can scale to
thousands of nodes,
and it scales horizontally
your schema, permitting.
If you want to learn a little
bit more about Cloud Spanner,
there's a shameless
plug at the bottom.
So if you search for
TIL about Cloud Spanner
you will find a
video series where
I go through some of the nitty
gritties and amazing things
that we do with Cloud Spanner.
So let's recap.
What is the portfolio under the
Google Cloud Storage or Google
Cloud Platform that we have
in terms of data and storage
products?
So we have covered Cloud SQL.
We have mentioned Cloud Spanner.
We have mentioned Cloud
Data Store or Firestore.
There are a couple of
others here on the slide.
So if you use App
Engine, you can
use, for instance,
App Engine Memcache.
If you have a lot of data
which you want to search really
fast, or process
really fast, you
want to have a very
high read throughput,
read and write throughput
for non-relational data,
then we recommend to
use Cloud Bigtable.
Cloud Bigtable has
an H base interface
so you can connect it
to your like Spark,
or things like that.
Then we also have a data
warehouse system, a managed
data warehouse system,
which is BigQuery,
where you can go and
load relational data in,
and crunch terabytes
of data with BigQuery.
All right, so with
this, I thank you
very much for your attention.
If you have any
questions, please
feel free to walk up
to the microphones.
I'm happy to answer
some of your questions.
And please also, if you want
to, follow me on Twitter
under @hostirosti.
And I'm happy to answer
any kinds of questions
through Twitter as well.
So thank you very much
for your attention.
I hope you enjoyed the talk.
And have a good Google I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]